[Applaudissements]
je crois considère les choses je ne suis
pas ton idée
écoute la société provoque redescendent
monter des stages je ne sais pas ce
qu'on dispose en jaune et statue cristal
je sais que nous au code soit mon visage
l'amour
est bizarre
à toi d'ouvrir les yeux est-ce que tu
envisages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis toutes les parties
si vous nous rejoignez que sont-elles
devenues les L5
[Applaudissements]
elles sont là elles sont avec nous
comment tu t'appelles
Clinton Clinton alors
Clinton normalement tu es pas la machine
a été dans une télé-réalité j'adore
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
tu en es où tu es marié fiancé on
concubinage célibataire d'accord
qu'est-ce que tu recherches les summer
body
[Applaudissements]
je suis une bête
tu peux toucher
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors tu recherches où tu t'es
tranquille toi tu veux moi j'adore les
meufs qui ont de l'humour tu vois déjà
franchement je suis plutôt tranquille je
suis plus une meuf qui voyage les avions
pourquoi tu veux un mec dans chaque
ville
comment ça va ton ma chérie d'amour je
suis content de l'avoir ça va chéri
bonsoir à tous bonsoir bonsoir sur la
tête de ma mère elle est persuadée
qu'elle a Miss France bonsoir à tous
je suis très heureuse d'être là
j'ai deux passions dans la vie le
boomerang et le tourisme
[Rires]
Jean-Luc Lahaye
femme je vous aime et bien moi j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui à tous les
Français que j'aime la rillette
non mais sérieux elle est pas comment tu
t'appelles
non mais alors
[Applaudissements]
t'as pas postulé chez un pote à moi qui
fait une pièce
elles sont en train de faire
connaissance les mains on est en train
de on se connaît déjà mais on parlera 2
minutes servez le raté voilà c'est bon
alors et donc quand tu connais est-ce
que tu prends dedans en fait les enfants
donc alors mais moi aussi j'ai vu plein
de femmes mais
attends merde pas d'accord
c'est quoi ton style j'aime bien les
hommes un peu comme toi
[Applaudissements]
tu seras morte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les gens comment ça va ma chérie salut
Kenza Kenza n'est pas peur ça va ma
chérie merci d'être là je suis content
je suis content que tu sois là je
t'embête pas plus d'accord ma chérie
comment ça va tu as pas l'air de ouf toi
mais vous venez de vous connaître ah
d'accord d'accord très bien et vous
c'est la cousine de oui ça va très bien
c'est quoi ton prénom Annie
tu vas lui faire un bisou j'adore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi moi j'ai envie j'ai envie de faire
kiffer le public et je vais commencer
par vous faire kiffer vous alors est-ce
que vous choisissez chacune quelqu'un
avec qui vous allez danser toi c'est
Bernard Montiel alors pourquoi pas tu te
mets à côté tu te mets à côté toi ma
chérie
c'est ça
mais Dory ça c'est une marque de chips
non
il faut du temps pour venir tandoori
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici
ma chérie
[Rires]
je le connais je le connais il va toutes
les Ken
vous toi aussi Merlin Bernard
et toi ma chérie alors
[Applaudissements]
Bernard
Bernard c'est très gentil toi plaisir
non mais c'est vrai à ton âge prends
tout ce qui est à prendre
c'est bien
il faut il faut y aller quoi il faut y
aller